[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us about
in a very particular context. text
he tells us about the story of Musam
when he first arrived
at the tree
on Mount Cyani.
He was traveling with his family
and they got lost on their way back to
Egypt
and
it was dark. It was nighttime. It was
bitter cold.
And Misam
saw a light, a glimmering, glowing light
in the darkness.
And he
thought that that light was another band
of travelers that had set up camp for
the evening.
And so Misam told his
family, "Wait here. I'm going to go to
that light over there. It's high up on
this mountain."
He's going to go up there
and speak to those travelers
and worst case scenario, he'll come back
with some fire so that they can make
their own camp. Best case scenario,
they'll know exactly where we are and
how to get home.
And so when Musam
got up to that light,
he found that that light there
was not actually a fire.
When he got up to that campfire that he
saw in the distance, the closer he got,
the more he realized that that is
actually not a fire.
It was actually pure light that was
coming out of a tree
there on that mountain.
And it was at that time that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala himself
spoke to Misam
and he tells him that he is Allah.
take your shoes off, establish prayer in
order to remember me, etc.
But one of the things that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioned to Ma
was a sentence that made sense of his
entire life
and the rest of his life will be an
explanation
of this sentence.
He said, "I have meticulously formed you
under my direct supervision,
and I have formed you to this point
exactly for my use, for my own uses, for
myself."
He says,
"I have designed and fashioned you up
until this point for my use."
Now this is a very interesting statement
because if we were to review
the life of Misam up until that point
it would be very difficult to make any
sense
of
the happenings in his life the
occurrences
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
chose that Mus Alisam
be born
during what would seem to be the worst
time
out of all times.
The worst time. He was born during the
year of genocide in Egypt.
He was born during the year of genocide.
Meaning that Pharaoh
he had a dream
that scared him.
He had a dream
just before Misam was born
that a child from Benel
is going to rise up and the end of your
reign will come at his hand.
when he spoke to his pundits and he
spoke to his advisors and asked them for
an interpretation of this dream.
They told him this dream means that
someone is being born right now in Beni
is
that is going to mark your descent.
And so what did Fan do?
What did he choose to do at that moment?
Pharaoh decided to work as hard as he
could to strain against the
will and decree of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
He decided
that every single child born this year
that is a male from Ben is to be killed.
Everyone
don't think that this is strange or this
is something that could never happen in
our time. Humanity, its history is
filled to the gills
with stories just this
where those in power are able to do to
their subjects
incredibly atrocious and vicious things.
And so Mus Alisam had he been born a
year earlier he would have escaped that.
Had he been born a year after he would
have been spared from that
Mosam was born during that year
specifically.
Allah chose that year.
If we were told at that time that
during these five or 10 years
the
of Allah the one who Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala chooses to raise up from Ben
the greatest of their messengers he's
going to be born during this time every
single one of us would skip that year we
we just couldn't process that Allah
subhanahuaa
will choose that specific year out of
all the years for him to be born. It
seems counterintuitive.
Allah chose that year. As a matter of
fact, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave him
that vision that year so that he would
do that.
This all falls back into
I personally have overseen your
development.
I fashioned you for my use.
Let me tell you brothers and sisters,
the greatest man or woman amongst us.
If you were to say who has the greatest
destiny out of anyone amongst us, it is
the one whom Allah has chosen to use for
his purposes.
That's the greatest thing that Allah
could choose to use you.
And Muslim Ahmed
Malik narrates that our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
whomever Allah desires good for him
chooses or wills good for him or her
he will use him before his death.
The companions,
they said, "Oh messenger of Allah, and
how does Allah use his servants?" He
said, "He will grant him righteous deeds
before his death."
The greatest thing that you or I could
ever hope or aspire to is to be used as
an instrument by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala on this earth to further his
revelation
subhanahu wa ta'ala. That's the greatest
destiny.
That's the greatest destiny. There is no
superior destiny to that.
There is no greater purpose than
if we were to look at in hindsight, if
we were to look at Mus Alam being born
during that year, we would all
collectively agree that definitely Musam
is not amongst these these children
because this is the worst possible year
to be born.
However,
not in spite of that year, but because
of that genocide during that year,
as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes
himself,
he brings forth the living from the
dead.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made it so that every newborn child is
now being hunted down and murdered.
Everyone unceremoniously.
They'll take the child, kill the kill
the child, give him back. That's it.
Why? Because Pharaoh said so. He has
decreed.
But Allah has decreed.
How are you going to hide an infant
newborn? How can you possibly hide an
infant newborn? You cannot.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
inspired the parents of Ma
and specifically his mother
with a long shot. What was the long
shot?
put him into a box,
a basket,
cover it up, and put it in the Nile.
If being taken and murdered is 100%
mortality, this is 0.05%
chance that he will survive. The Nile,
sometimes if if you've never seen the
Nile River, you would assume, yeah, it's
a little cute river. No, this is a river
that is raging.
This is a river that has monsters in it.
This is not just a regular river. It's
one of the four biggest rivers on all of
planet Earth.
What are the chances?
But she does it. And he washes up right
at the feet of Pharaoh.
Now, you would think that of all the
children he would choose to kill, this
specific one would be the one he would
most choose to kill.
I mean, , , you decree that a
newborn,
every newborn be killed,
and here one magically washes up at your
feet.
However, his wife pleads with him, he'd
be a great son, we could utilize him in
the future, etc., etc., etc. Allah used
Musa's mother.
Allah now uses Pharaoh's wife
and he begrudgingly accepts.
But who was watching the whole time?
MS's sister Mariam Alisam
not Mariam the mother of Isaam
Mariam the sister of Mus
Harun is Mus's older brother he was not
under this threat he was born years
before
and his mother had said to her follow
this child down the river as much as you
can try to keep up with him and see
where he washes up she watches this
whole thing unfold
Pharaoh begrudgingly accepts
to
to you know to coexist with his wife.
Imagine the power that a woman holds.
A man Pharaoh
can decree the murder of every newborn
in an entire society.
But he bends to the will of a woman, one
single woman.
And so
Pharaoh
decides to spare this child.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala makes it
that MS will only suffer from his mother
for a number of reasons.
And so they are trying to get this child
to suckle from anyone. hundreds of
servants in the palace of Pharaoh and he
will not accept from anyone.
The sister then says, "You know what? I
heard you guys are having some trouble.
I know a family that could probably
suckle this child for you." And he
returns Musam to his mother. And now
they are existing in the open right
under Pharaoh's nose, not in spite of
the genocide, but because of the
genocide that year this happened.
We fast forward,
we notice that one of the most
prominent,
one of the most prominent features or
descriptions of Musam
is that he is.
He is the one who speaks directly to
Allah.
If I were to give you a description, I
say, imagine for me a man amongst
humanity that speaks directly to
Almighty Allah himself. How eloquent and
beautiful would you imagine this man to
be.
However, that is exactly the opposite.
Moshadam is an infant
and he's playing there in the palace
with Pharaoh. And as some narrations
mention from the companions, every time
Pharaoh picks this kid up, he reaches up
and whips out hairs from Pharaoh's chin.
He had a beard. Pharaoh had a beard. I
know in in the movies, Pharaoh is
this kind of shaved down linky
character, but that's exactly the
opposite of what he looked like. He had
very long beard. And every time he picks
this child up, the kid reaches up and
starts ripping his beard out.
And so Pharaoh starts to get suspicious
of this kid.
says, "Every time I pick him up, he's
only ripping my beard out."
And so they say, "He's a child." You
know, I mean, how reasonable is it to
think that this newborn is somehow has
it out for you? He says, "No, I'm not
convinced. I think he knows what he's
doing.
Let him choose."
They put a date for him and a lit ember,
a cold
And they have this child shoes. And
Misam with his little infant hands at
the moment reaches out to grab the date.
And Jirelam
pushes his hand towards the coal. He
picks it up and puts it in his mouth,
permanently scarring his tongue.
After this, Mus Alam never spoke
properly again in public.
He had a lisp.
And if anyone's ever heard a lisp, it's
it's not the most flattering of features
for a prominent speaker to have.
We see that Musam then grows up.
He sees that there's a conflict going
on. He accidentally kills a man from the
Pharaohs.
Now he takes off into the desert,
running out into the desert, fleeing as
a fugitive of justice. Everyone is
looking for MSA.
If we were to stop at this moment and
say, "You see this man right now, this
young boy running in the desert as a
fugitive, the one with the lisp, the one
who neither seems to fit in with Ben nor
with the pharaohs, the one who was born
during the year of the genocide.
This this young man is going to be in a
decade
the most greatest and prominent
messenger of Allah
of all of Bi is. No one has come from
the lineage of his half more
awesome in
stature than Musam. This young man
running in the desert. this fugitive
here with the lisp. He is going to be
the greatest messenger of Bani.
That would be pretty hard to believe at
that time.
But when Musam
stood on that mountain,
when he stood on Mount Si in the dark,
in the rain, in the thunder,
when he saw that light, when Allah spoke
to him
and he spoke back to Allah and Allah
told him,
I have designed you meticulously ly for
my own purposes.
It all made sense. It all snapped into
place at that moment. Of course, every
one of these things was perfectly
designed and fashioned for MS to find
himself on that mountain that night at
exactly the place where Allah had
decreed for him.
And this takes us back to a statement
that Allah tells us about Zechariah.
At 120 years old, Allah informs
Zechariah that he's going to have a son
finally. Why didn't you give me a son
when I was 20 or 30 or 50? Heck, 70 or
even 80 would have would have done.
He gives him a son at 120 years old.
But when the angels came to give him
that news, even though he didn't
understand the plan of Allah or the use
of Allah,
Allah tells us
the angels called out to him while he
was busy praying.
That's the point here. You don't know
what Allah is going to do. The point is
is that you make yourself ready.
That when Allah finds you
to use you, hopefully that is should be
your greatest aspiration that Allah
choose to use you. He finds you in a
place that he is pleased with.
It is not your position or my position
to worry about what Allah is doing to
me.
and forget what Allah has commanded of
me. My job is to focus on what Allah has
commanded me. It's not my job to try to
figure out what Allah is doing and why
and and what is the the that is not at
all my business. I am Allah's subject
and I am entirely subject to his will.
My position
is to make sure that I am always ready
for when that critical moment comes that
I may be called on by Allah.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
for
[Silence]
all
Alhamdulillah.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
I
Allah.
[Silence]
So,
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Align your
shoulders and your feet with the
shoulders and feet of your two neighbors
on either side of you. Straightening our
rows is paramount and incredibly
important. We will largely be judged and
rewarded on our prayer today based on
how straight and coherent our rows are.
Do not join a row unless the row in
front of you is completely filled to
capacity. Please double check your
phones. Ensure that your phones are
completely silent.
[Silence]
Jim.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Canister.
Amen.
[Silence]
Fore! Foreign! Foreign! Foreign!
All
the clouds.
So me
Allah
All
[Silence]
align.
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
lost for
whatever
happy
[Silence]
Allah
Allah.
[Silence]
I love
the
[Silence]
Allah.
before the announcements very quickly
one of our sisters Dr. Fana her
father passed away. F is Hussein.
we are just going to make a very brief
dua for him.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Brother and sisters, I just wanted to
share with you a couple of reminders.
First one isalam
alalaykum. I hope you can hear me better
now. couple of reminders only.
Tonight is a youth night. So and there
is a the feature of that is the halaka
hadis haka with Imam Ali inshallah at
7:30 p.m. So if you are able to attend
that will be very important. Bring your
youth with you inshallah. Also on the
Saturday and Sunday we have Quran halaka
after fudar and we would to invite
more of you to come and join us
inshallah and that is very enjoyable and
we learn a lot from sheikh Ali it's
after fajar on Saturday and Sunday
mornings the last thing I want to
mention is the Sunday program it is one
opportunity that you have to attend
attach your youth to the masid
and Imam Ali can guide us inshallah your
youth. So it's going to be every Sunday
from 10:30 to 1:30 10:30 a.m. to 1:30
p.m. So if you have a youth that can
benefit from it, please come and join on
this Sunday
and donate generously on the way out.
[Silence]
Bronco here. I said I want them.
I'm never going to let that go. So the
floor
[Silence]
by
your bike.